There was once a beautiful princess named Snow White.
She had an evil stepmother...
...who thought she was more beautiful than anyone else.
But Snow White was more beautiful,...
...so her stepmother tried to have her killed.
Luckily, Snow White escaped...
...and lived in the forest with seven dwarfs.
They all lived happily, until the mirror told her stepmother...
...that Snow White was still alive.
The wicked stepmother disguised herself as a peddler.
Then she went to the cottage while the seven dwarfs were at work.
She gave Snow White a poisoned red apple.
Snow White took a bite of the apple and fell into a deep sleep.
The dwarfs were very sad and built a glass coffin for her.
One day, a prince came by and saw her.
He bent down to give her a kiss.
Snow White woke up and they got married.